pictorial record of the tragedy of the
hindenburg may 6 1937 and the airship
soon to be a twisted massive metal as a result
of a fire that occurred at lakehurst new jersey
even as hundreds hailed the dirichlet's arrival
from hamburg germany passes over new york city
catastrophe in the making storm
clouds gather over the jersey coast
and lakehurst is a welcome sight
to zeppelin passengers and crew
winds with the mooring lines then as its
passengers watch tragedy strikes a terrific
explosion in the tail fit of the dirigible
and passengers and crew hurl themselves out
of the ship into the ground navy and army
men risk their lives as the fire eats its
way through seven million feet of inflammable
hydrogen gas and leaves a steel skeleton in
its wake only a miracle save those who are
fortunate enough to quit the ship in time
but 36 of the 97 people aboard perished in
the most horrible air disaster of all time
hundreds of tons of fuel oil burned
for an hour after the explosion
the dense black smoke giving a funeral touch
to the sky that sped the hindenburg to its doom
only ten minutes and the airship would
have been moored safely but it required
less than one minute for it to turn from a
luxury ship to an incandescent death trap
included in the list of fatalities
was captain ernst leemon
commander of the hindenburg who perished as
the pride of the has reached its journey's end